[Music]  you might be the prettiest pregnant lady  on the red carpet ever very very kind  thank you we're just created just for  you actually it was really lucky it just  came off the runway last week and  crazily fit shocking I'll do that means  you're perfectly pregnant easily it was  very loose on the model you have a name  yet no no no that I'm just not gonna  tell no no no you gotta meet a baby  before we're gonna be here before he or  her kind of meet the baby and figure it  out yeah how does it feel to be walking  the Sangh red ward the ssag red carpet  as a nominee it's wonderful I really I'm  so proud of the film Jackie and to be  here with the people I love working with  all the actors and especially at a  moment that's dark in our country's  history to be you know celebrating art  and people trying to express human  emotion and be empathetic towards other  people's good  [Music]  you